hi I'm here with Greg this is King David
and we're with bowl-cut studios Brett
tell us more about your game alright
it's called mage quit it's a top down
wizard brawler for up to 10 players
online or local before each round you
draft a new spell and every kill you get
makes your beard longer wizard with the
longest beard after nine rounds wins
well now you know I can respect the long
beard and I'm highly intriguing than
this question so do they battle against
each other or they're battling as a team
against another team so you can do
either one there's teams and there's and
there's free-for-all as well and I
noticed that you using the Unity engine
yes we are yeah unity does that allow a
lot of flexibility when it comes to the
graphics and the dynamics of the world
it's I mean it allows for faster
prototyping and world building for sure
but the big advantage for us is is for
releasing to multiple platforms that was
our main reason for going with it
fantastic and how long has it been in
development so Chad and I have been
working on the game for for three years
actually a little more than three years
now but we both had full-time jobs for
well chad still does I just finally went
full-time on this six six weeks ago so
so we're really cranking out content
questions so it's a two-man team it is
it's just me my brother Chad so I do the
programming and the game design and he
does the art and animation that is
highly phenomenal for a two-man team to
get a game of this magnitude out and
when are you projecting a release day so
it's already on Steam early access some
people can play it now but we're
thinking probably q3 of next year for a
full release to all the platforms will
be on which is pc nintendo switch xbox
one and potentially playstation we
haven't we actually haven't talked to
them about it yet
awesome so this is Bo touch studios with
mage Quint and that was Brett and this
is Lord King David and we're gonna give
you some action with more of the Lords
playing this fantastic game
we actually got all
right team
let's see
a new element
just relax attendees
saying it's playing first movie posted
online
yeah
so it's jumping at any time yeah
well we came up with that idea
Natacha wheeling
shout out the true game players in the
building let's go
okay Bachchan
here I get buffalo
there you go
now we got a creator no you got to
create it as an ax bag on a controller
[Applause]
Oh
this is Balkan
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh boy here we go
[Music]
[Music]
ha ha - whoo
[Applause]
MJ's fighting tomorrow
shoutout to the blue team
and she talked about
development power
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
for their country
[Music]
Merlin
[Music]
shout out to the dance from Botox
studios
[Applause]
it is a slob
PT's thought he was coming over here
with the ring of business
done
little dude this is rap
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
every time I can think what I'm like
Oh everybody got a little island
exclusive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
they're jumping in
and I'll fight it off
[Applause]
and others
and yet the blue team wins yet again
I think they're gonna have to split up
the booty
who has read
[Applause]
[Applause]
she said I'll never tell I don't know
yeah right the first movie
I notice you can do defensive moves
that's so somebody put up a stone shoe
yeah
so it's not
offensive
Oh
[Music]
as I acid
rage quit
two men development
[Applause]
well you know five or five
was a
for Xbox switch and
level maids bite
[Music]
No
Oh No
oh you know here's silently winning
or a spitfire spell at hi
that jet stream
[Applause]
I'm super simple design
[Music]
it seems super like a super sister
combinations over with all the
you'll notice that all the spells that
people have their different spells is to
go
where are you going baby
[Applause]
you're not the lava baby
laughs - blue
sacrebleu sock live Harry's ahead
Perry's a lone fighter
oho very very crazy Oh Harry's was stood
all day
tell them oh no Harry the dead son
number let's see me
okay oh he just jumped at him he went
for the kill
that is savage 26 the 13
winds down deep rolling in
Oh Jetstream with the combined class
get out of the bushes
Oh Gandalf is out here bogarting and
being beasty
Oh gah noses in the bushes and he's down
sovereign just made it back in
Oh red team is not trying to hear it
this round sobbing uh /
they cut them in sand
these still surround us
the last round
[Music]
alright versus blue what will you do